hey guys new podcast uh sorry it's late
this week I've just been really busy i'm
in baltimore right now next week i'm
shooting birth conquer and ohio and then
i am in dayton the weekend after that
irvine in december posted a new video to
my YouTube page my vlog it's hung out I
just basically recorded a day of working
on the set of birth conquer it's pretty
funny starts in the morning and ends at
night that's when a day works [ __ ]
way to go dummy I'm a [ __ ] idiot
sometimes I'm having a little bit of a
rough patch right now guys Michael idea
um those my tour dates check out my
youtube channel go to / / / calm and you
get all my tour dates and you can
subscribe to my youtube channel you
click the link and I just like I posted
the cap cattle auction from trip flip it
is hilarious if you like me laughing it
is seven minutes of me laughing I just
laughed the hardest I've ever laughed
and I got the vietnamese ear cleaning i
get the world's tallest stadium jump on
there I'm putting a putting out content
folks December is gonna be a Content
month you get it ready hold on to your
britches ah today's guest is a hilarious
dude he is just funny he's the guy you'd
be blessed to live with in the 20s in
your building you're like tank otic
others across all for me I'm gonna my
life is better because of him he's a
reason [ __ ] man and I love that about
[ __ ] comics that [ __ ] [ __ ] Onan
he's got a podcast on the sideshow
network called puck off he he tours with
Lisa Lampanelli and I think bill burr
easy talks we talk about all this on the
podcast put your hands together just
clap she's clap by yourself for Joe
burning
but not that I have anything that I know
is it not pushed in all the way let me
turn no wait wait I'll leave those on in
case your wife wants to talk yeah don't
let her this is a man kick sit outside
please um I I'm what sucks is when I do
these podcasts like this where I try to
bang out a bunch mom in town mmm the
same thought it's like I did I've done
hang almost talked in there hello hello
lo it sounds perfect Burt spike in and
then a few of these I'll turn this down
just so that I get loud it's perfect the
matters but no it's fine that's perfect
the the thing that happens is I end up
talking a lot about the same three
things because that's what's going on
yeah and sorry I like right now I'm
obsessed with this article I read about
the coddling of the American mind and
it's about you're luckier here today
yesterday I did a podcast and I didn't
put the AC on I didn't I didn't have it
set up yet oh yeah [ __ ] sweltering in
here but uh but yeah so I read this
article and it's all about trigger
warnings and and and vindictive policing
that's happening online with people it's
really i'm really glad the conversations
happening oh yeah i just retweeted an
Ari Shaffir or yesterday Richard about
how there's actually people now cultural
libertarians that are like anti
right-wing anti left-wing that just went
free speech to be heard I mean this
stand-up comics that's all we want you
know it's like they're it's the police
like oh you can't rip on this person you
can't rip on this person it's like oh
it's just horrible it's I'm so stupid
though that I read an article that makes
sense and then I go that make sense and
then I'm and then and then I read
another article that negates it I go
that makes sense too and then I go then
I read another article on go huh maybe
even more so like I read this article
defiant you know trigger warnings right
actually I don't okay
good morning I was trying to write a
joke last night about how trigger
warnings are there in school right now
and they're all online and it's
basically when anyone who suffered any
trauma any type of trauma be a sexual
assault be it uh by the way I should say
a trigger warning before I even talked
about trigger warnings I think I think
you're supposed to say trigger warning
like I know the new word this is my safe
space Burke yeah that's what it is it's
basically so students will say I don't
want you to talk I don't want you to
teach about slavery to a teacher because
it is it brings up feelings for them and
so they don't want like those feelings
by the way I'm bastardizing whatever
this is but this is technically it and
so I read an article about it last night
and it's mostly to a sexual assault and
it's with people for that traumatic
experience stress traumatic stress have
PTSD about an event so a teacher will is
forced not forced I think he chooses to
do it but a listen trigger warning today
we're going to be talking about said
subject so every time i hear glove side
i think at tom barrasso giving up a bag
on 1993 yeah i'm a traumatic moment like
her a so didn't give us get his club up
the dynasties over that's it technically
that really is kind of what it is it's
something that pulls back something that
makes you angry or upset or hurt or
causes anxiety it's a pen and it's this
whole debate that's going on it seems
this week like this last couple weeks
especially guy wrote an article in the
Atlantic about it and then another guy
wrote one in The New Yorker and then
someone wrote one about Jimmy Fallon's
ring finger and like like equivalent
trigger warnings to just to like to like
hey do you want to watch two guys with
two girls one cop and then ultimately a
trigger warning is just give me a heads
up it's [ __ ] disgust just giving you
a heads up this is something that you
may [ __ ] you up right like that's a
trigger warning is technically it's
because Fallon did it he said I'm gonna
don't even Google what happened to my
finger if you don't want to be
[ __ ] disgusted because what happened
it founds finger apparently his ring
almost ripped off his [ __ ] finger did
you hear about when he was drunk on TV
or no dear was I think he was drunk in a
bar fell or he tried to catch someone's
drink who and end his ring almost ripped
off his [ __ ] finger oh and so exactly
and so he went online on TV the next day
to talk about what happened and he said
listen I'll tell you what happened but
do not google it cuz you'll have a hard
time forgetting a videotaped yeah oh no
no no there's just images of it images
of it so not of this finger but of
people it's happened too and it's
[ __ ] disgusting so basically what the
temple was equivalent at to trigger
warnings saying that's what a trigger
warning is just a heads up and then
someone said well no you can't do that
with students because we're raising I'm
reading all these articles my point was
that my point of getting all this was I
was trying to write it a joke and then I
was like don't even [ __ ] go there I
don't want those those people that get
[ __ ] vindictive and want to ruin your
career that are online you know those
people that just like just try to
destroy you in every way possible right
I don't want them against me I don't
want to talk to any of them right and
it's scary because it's funny when you
go when you say stuff that someone might
get if that's the funny stuff well it's
it's it's it's neat this is trigger
warning this it's but it's fun plan in
your dad's garage with gunpowder if
those are the times I remember the most
is when we found a [ __ ] bottle rocket
and we opened it up and spread gunpowder
in the garage that's animate like it's
dangerous as [ __ ] you may burn your
boxers and light your nuts on fire right
but it it when it does work you know
there's nothing better than getting a
joke that's well-crafted and is and it's
taking a chance and and and it works and
other comics respect it and the audience
expects it yeah beautiful [ __ ] app
that's my favorite as they're all my
jokes those are my favorite types of
jokes that's what uh you know whatever
not named Rob but that's what bill says
he loves especially in Boston
went after the people and they were just
like he loved the fact they were just
like yeah yeah like we'll take it bring
it on Bill's a perfect example he did
the you know bills someone who pushes
who goes for the thing that no one's
going for or he tackles a subject that
and that I enjoy watching that cuz it's
the thing that I haven't written about
yet you know right and I think that and
it's the thing I haven't thought about
the way he thought about it was
different we know like and that those
are the comics I enjoy watching right
now have I seen them go too far of
course but as a fan of comedy I give
them that allowance honestly I've never
seen anybody go to 0 I of course we have
well it would say it's like I mean I
think people go too far when they [ __ ]
on a room no oral I mean you've we've
all seen we've all seen guys take a
chance where you're like where he even
they laugh it off they're like okay [ __ ]
it a try personally but I mean do you
think they're suck I mean the only
subject that I think is kind of off what
which like I i can even laugh at a
Wellcraft the one but I don't do is I
don't do rape jokes I don't yeah and
that's not because I think some of them
aren't funny that is because to me I
don't wanna I don't want to perpetuate
that I just that's not my cuppa tea it's
not but it's nice but I'll afford a
well-crafted one oh yeah others said
I've seen I've seen tosh take big
[ __ ] swings ok yeah he and and anger
and big swings right and he goes places
where not a lot of people are going
right and I've seen I've seen I wasn't
offended by no stretch it means I'm a
powerful individual you can't offend me
right no part of any word you can say to
me right go to offend me and then I sit
in bed with it the [ __ ] like that
doesn't exist in my world right that's
not a comic also and I know his attempt
is not to try to make someone upset and
angry but to make them laugh right and
I've taken big chances and missed and
like on stage where you think something
is going to work brilliantly and and you
just miss and that I but I allow a comic
that but isn't that just missing or is
that thinking it's going to eight is it
is going to your
too far is it just not funny you know I
don't think there's any part that's
passed to know I don't think yeah I
don't think I was trying to get up
before yeah you might be right about let
me know everything can be I mean Dana
Gould remember his last but or maybe
saying this page like it my first
rejection me about like AIDS rape and
something else and again and they all
worked like hilariously you know Oh
route I don't think you can go let me
rephrase that you're right about that
I'm wrong you can't go too far as a
comic there's nothing out of bounds my
pin that's what I kind of wanted we up
but I've seen people take the step into
the dark territory miss and have to come
back right and those mrs. are what Pete
get people [ __ ] up in arms and I rate
and I go that's you can't do that in too
far is almost like deep-sea diving where
the younger the comic the less deep he
can go like there was jokes that I did
like two years in that were horrific to
people then now is like rated G compared
to what I can get away with now oh it's
how you learn how to swim the depths of
how to get into a sub and just like
deep-sea diving it takes very long to
get up from this those deep places right
you got to go 10 feet a minute and you
gotta hang out the last 15 feet yeah oh
there she is and so but I i I'll i
respect the guys that go [ __ ] deep oh
yeah well does he really I mean
literally the only comics that i watch
are the people like or bill or jim
jefferies pushes the envelope when Brees
he pushes the own they're the only
comics I think that regular comics like
us what not regular whatever was a pro
where he was say common watch cuz
they're the people that are interesting
yeah they're the people that are
genuinely interesting other people that
you go you go that's he's he's tackling
something I you know like he's going
somewhere were I haven't thought of and
that's you know and sometimes the places
you haven't thought is like like Jimmy
Carr we went you know Jimmy Carr no he's
a British comic and his [ __ ] genius
he is genius and we went and did a
cancer like not a hospice house like a
cancer recovery house and Jimmy's like
in the
and he's like zeni one talking about
cancer today and I'm like no by the way
that's a no I'm not saying that's not
the comic I am right maybe if I have the
right joke I don't have a lot I don't
have any cancer jokes right alone do I
think that I could pull it off today
because I'm nervous and I'm nervous
about performing in front of a bunch of
people who have or are getting through
or possibly dying with from cancer in a
room that's just them in their Center
that they're not center of a house that
they're living in right I'm nervous
about that I'm nervous about that Jimmy
cars going right for the [ __ ] throat
he's like no that's what I do like cats
but that makes jimmy carr jimmy carr and
and I when he did it his opening joke
was like can we talk about cancer like
that better he's closing the show no
one's going after him to [ __ ] clean
it up if he doesn't do well right this
is in that that fearlessness I don't
that's like watching the guys that rock
climb not use a rope you know yeah yeah
I can't even watch those guys on TV it
makes me sick yeah you know I can't even
you know I'll tell you this makes me
sick in our local pizza shop they have
the picture of the Italians all sitting
on like the Empire State Building I
can't even look at how are they sitting
there I look at that I look at that
picture so much I mean I think I read
something about how they took that
picture they were super glue this that
was the my hands are sweating thinking
yeah it's not that that whole um that
whole time I guess there was an Indian
tribe that was not afraid of heights the
tribe wasn't afraid about it yeah that's
that movie wolfin is based on never see
the movie Wulfen know it had a tit shot
we were like in third grade she had the
tivo know whatever my tivo what would
like stay up effin make sure you caught
the tit stay up I yet i would i would
vcr it when i would do is i would like I
remember VCR Aang things that I thought
might get it and I just hit record and
I'm wait until I like I mean I became
good at plot deconstruction to be like
like the name of the Rose was the first
one where I was like all right this is
definitely out of nudity throw a blank
tape in and I'm just
sitting there waiting and waiting and
waiting and then when I see Christian
whatever walk into the room by himself
I'm like here's where it starts again
I'm like come on come on make it happen
making it but I'm like checking over my
shoulder and then all sudden they start
[ __ ] I'm like that's what I knew it
nailed it well you can tell from the
guide when it would say like strong
sexual content it's like that's the one
the watch dude I there was like I wished
I could have gotten into like so many
there's so many things that I wished I
could have rented when I was a kid
there's this movie called Gator bait
that I saw every house great hulking day
I I literally every time we went to the
rental store it was like Gator bait it
was in a glass case yeah and I remember
keep saying like Santa my dad like
casually like do you think that was good
i mean we live on a lake we like Gators
Dean in our Wi-Fi um it is what is our
Wi-Fi I think it's my phone number wait
do you know if we know what though like
like there's just those moments in time
though like you just had to be like
dressed to kill I don't all a ball did
it work all right you're all nine I just
gave her my but I password herpes boy 33
warning you've got AIDS that's always
but uh no like the added time of
perfectly like dress to kill with Angie
Dickinson naked in the shower was always
just like the first 10 minutes so you
could even put it out where like all
your grandma's in this room your mom's
upstairs like okay it's on right now I
wish I wish there was you know what I
miss about masturbating is uh is the
urgency with wash it with which it was
show up when I was younger the bit and
but I'm saying like before I don't want
some like an old man but before the
internet before all that there was like
you wouldn't be thinking about it and
then something would pop up like there
was this thing called foxy boxing in in
Tampa and you know Ron Bennington and
name sounds familiar Ron and Fez he's
out of uh okay okay that's Ron okay I
think Ron would host foxy boxing and it
but it would be on channel 32 what's
better no go ahead what's runner I did
that I don't want the the key
okay okay carrot all right these bikes
are [ __ ] horrible um foxy boxing was
on um channel 32 or 30 was 32 or 48 and
we just come on at like midnight and it
the second it would come on every part
of me would just go let's go right now
then and it was in like I have not
there's gonna sound sad but I haven't
like I I don't think I've masturbated
once in the maybe the past 10 years
where I was aroused first it's more like
a decision like I guess I could do that
and then I have to work it up like as
opposed to like it's there and then I go
well let's take care of this you know
what I mean yeah that no I easily jerk
off because i am horny no i'm not horny
sometimes I'm just like bored no yeah
well that's look no I do that too when
you're like okay well I just did the
treadmill well I mean I right thought I
did triple for a while now I have three
hours to the show I'm in the jerk for
the nap yeah you know a jerk I'll do it
I'll do it when I'm hungover to boost up
my serotonin I'll be like I don't feel
so good I bet if I jerked off I can go
back to bed who call me down right like
uh yeah i mean it's it's a medical jerk
yeah my wife came into this morning to
have sex he ended up talking she was
like oh my god like first time ever we
talked instead of having sex and then i
go we could have sex like yeah do you
think you could do it quick and I was
like well give me a second like it was
more like I don't even know if I really
wanted have sex I just knew that if I
didn't do it then that I wouldn't get it
for a while like like it was on the
table so I was like well [ __ ] hold on
let me get ready like let me prep
everything but I don't yeah i don't i
don't know dude what do you sort of
pittsburgh aye sir comedy in san
francisco we're really yeah how did you
get how did you get out San Francisco
basically I wanted to live in the city
that I thought was like the boom of
comedy and you know in the Grateful Dead
and just part in San Francisco was
awesome until you know like basically
the computer industry ruined it really
when we return Francisco uh from the
early 90's until 2007 really aight
whenever whenever it's a hurricane
katrina that's the weekend I moved to LA
I knew that because
all of our [ __ ] was lost for a couple
days but we did bring one TV down so we
could like hook up DIRECTV yeah on our
little TV it's like we're watching
everyone else lose all their [ __ ] so we
couldn't really feel that bad about it
like I know my big TVs on the truck
somewhere it's not floating in the gulf
of mexico or whatever did this is this
is gonna sound very morbid but it do you
enjoy not enjoy but do you like when
those big national disasters happen do
you find it comforting to sit by the TV
and watch it and follow it for four days
no I know as a matter of fact like after
nine eleven I was actually the first day
we got direct TV I'll never forget this
was nine ten and I love the fact that we
had direct TV on 911 cuz I could just
watch boomerang oh you don't watch it
much like the looney tunes and stuff you
don't watch those obsessively no not at
all oh do not at all I'm horrible I
really yeah like I start getting
depressed when I feel like the coverage
is falling out like when people stop
caring hey wait a second there's another
tragedy hold on I'm not done with this
one by one of my favorite things is I
don't know I hope that there's someone
that is hearing this at least in going
like he's not a bad person he's just
there's some condition to this but like
when hurricane season happens I [ __ ]
track hurricanes on weather channel all
the time and if it if it's gonna touch
land um I'm like um I leave it on when
I'm on the road I leave it on when I go
to the club and when I come home I
almost like it's almost like a blanket I
get in bed and I'm like oh let's watch
what's going on with west gym can't own
doing there's your TiVo know you like
hurricanes like oh there's a new one cut
come home and there's like four new
hurricanes on your TiVo we haven't had
tivo and so long but I still say tebow I
still say TiVo yeah we in whatever
direct whatever yeah I was like
coca-cola make sure you tebow it and
yeah it's like what but yeah I'm were uh
I I'm this is sabbath like i'm out of
this house so much these days that
nothing i watch is recorded any more
like I've been taking all I've been
taking off the like that's sad
like it's all Teen Titans go it's all
the kids stuff is like the first nine
and then it's like Downton Abbey true
detective like all the and [ __ ] and then
maybe there's a 34-30 on there and the
only thing I yeah my old tivo the one
that read the one that I still have it
yeah it literally has like the archives
of the greatest things in the world it's
like Lemieux goals and steeler super
bounces on that team like all the
highlights but that one died so the new
one I mean all I really care about is
making sure that i have my hockey
highlights every night for my podcast
after that it's the late the ladies my
me my daughter watches oh just last
night she is watching such crime I come
with the family why listen on your iPad
so she was watching this [ __ ] that was
so hurtful to my soul I'm like we're
gonna watch Tom Sawyer with that with
jodie foster with [ __ ] Joe that's what
we watch they called him in Jinja yeah
and that was my nickname back in
pittsburgh was [ __ ] Joe and I so scared
[ __ ] Joe when I was a kid too really
wait wait wait what uh hold on what was
she gonna watch she's which like boy
meets world or grows with a new one with
Topanga and Fred's I know they living
and married and they live in New York
and like and they're supposed to live in
New York I'm like no one in New York has
apartment that's let that nice list her
name Trump yeah and no one he still
looks like a child the Ben Savage yeah
it was just so this plaque I worked and
if it worked in a aquarium store and all
they sold was goldfish I'm like that's
really gonna pay the rent at fourth and
eighth Avenue that's when you know
that's when you know the city like I
used to watch friends and go that's not
what a subway station looks clean and
they just walked in so what do you guys
I go where's the homeless guy playing
bongos on it on a tin can oh my god
that's the worst especially the hotter
it gets the more annoying the the drum
circle with the with the buckets like I
didn't I don't mind I didn't mind the
the breakdancing as much is that the
drum circle like my favorite part of New
York is the guys who go to Washington
Square and dive over people
you ever see those guys I know you're
talking about young black kid just dive
over [ __ ] 18 people and everyone just
gets around starts clapping it's the
weirdest [ __ ] like they had it in
Montreal like it when we were Montreal
they had those people that would jump
over people really oh yeah it's like
like I used to be really good at that as
a kid I could dive over a hedge and land
and dive into a diving roll I you really
good at that as kid it's be very
acrobatic yeah oddly enough i'm so
[ __ ] fat right now you look good even
working out thank you thank you liz is
it can we cut this as a highlight clip
and send it to my mom send to my dad
yeah I know I lost I've lost like 25
pounds anyway you know I just trying to
be healthier and I had a map you know
just had to lose some weight how'd you
do it how did I lose some weight uh it
stopped enjoying myself is it all around
diet um a lot a lot less drinking done a
lot less and kind of like no red meat
and kind of just being a queer at night
like I'll have some frozen grapes and
not like chocolate-covered Twinkies the
VIII I am really good until like [ __ ]
four o'clock like right now all I've had
is a shake I like a really healthy shake
protein powder mean green on unsweetened
almond milk and some berries and then I
had some egg whites and chopped up
chicken breast wow that's all yeah
that's really healthy like I'm really
held in place I've been doing that I've
been doing the treadmill a lot uh i have
i've been walking roughly about 10 miles
a day on my fitbit like around 25,000
steps a day so I've been working out
like crazy yeah we write you good
thought about what happened no i'm the
fattest I've ever [ __ ] been really
and the fat sunshine when we hugged I
was like that's a man it's my back um I
mean oh you're like you're like I like
the kind of quota tell so I love that
you're like steak fat you're not like
jelly doughnut fat steak fat that's a
good man leaf at like I guess I was I
mean I was when I'm big I look like Tony
Soprano
have like a a jiggly fat yeah I don't
have a disgusting fat that's a that's a
gay fat that is not like a man fat I
like I'm very big uh I'm like that i
like i like i still like lifting weights
and I my thing is walking but the
problem is I get to like dinner last
night and I'm like if we [ __ ] my wife
goes let's do leftovers we were cooking
all weeks I've been here so um we do
leftovers and it's like meatloaf ribs
like beef ribs pork ribs they're like
you know like only a few left but I have
two kids all having one rib and then
there's like two extra ribs and then a
beef rib and then half a half a thing a
meatloaf I ate so [ __ ] much last
night and then I sleep and I wake up on
the same [ __ ] wait I worked out a ton
I Heath I eat healthy half the [ __ ]
day but muscle is also muscle weighs
more than fat so if you're working at
you could be a lot thinner fat wise but
the muscles heavier I gotta like tell
myself it's it's they say it should be
like based on how your pants fit but
like man when you start gaining weight
sweatpants are such enablers they really
they're literally like the friend that's
like come on man you'll have a problem
have one drink right and jeans are like
the strict [ __ ] they're like [ __ ]
dude one drink means you're gonna get
[ __ ] hammered and because I can't die
jeans I have one pair of jeans that I
can wear can't wear them right out of
the washer like out of the washer I
gotta put them on and stretch him out
and then I can wear them and then once
they've been worn for like five days
they start getting comfortable yeah
that's I mean literally what happened to
me was going up I was at the hotel you
know like an hour to go home like two
blocks from Gotham no problem I
literally the jeans i packed my black
jeans my nice ones non faded like it's
not yeah yeah yeahs hiding me and versi
all in baby dude I get up to like my
knee and I like oh oh that is the worst
[ __ ] feeling when you when they get
MIG fine you're like this isn't making
over the app it's not 9000 like it wear
shorts my first leg or I could wear like
dirty like blue jeans that were on the
plane like uh yeah I literally do a cert
I could do a circle around you know
Manhattan is like 30 stores on the block
none could
find any black I'm like oh my god
everywhere I finally I didn't like the
buffalo exchange and I'm like I'm
looking for a Glee this big I know if it
was a girl that's gonna be a boy or a
burro that's gonna be a girl i'm not
quite sure which one but she's like big
black bigger to me was like we need help
with sweetheart and I'm like I need
something that I need jeans my boys can
fit in tune he goes he or she's like I
know that save my ass and I whenever
they go I go every her [ __ ] well if you
that I go I don't even care it was
twenty bucks in boom save save the day
but ya know I only have like two pairs
of jeans that fit you know it's like I I
what I want there to be um uh I went to
get i went to gap i had a pair of jeans
that were too tight I went to gap I'm
and here's the problem my body is like
my legs are a size you know like my legs
and calves are a size 36 my waist is a
size 38 so like it's in the ball game I
know but no I'm saying like meaning when
I put on a pair of 38 s they feel
comfortable but they look ugly on the
look ugly on me when I primary 36 they
look good on me but they're
uncomfortable yeah what I can sense a
hundred percent and I always go with
relaxed fit an ROV [ __ ] what I look like
I look I always go you go tightening and
uncomfortable I go tight uncomfortable
because I believe that'll get me to lose
weight yeah I just go no because then i
go tight uncomfortable I'm not
comfortable on stage and then it's like
then whatever like the men oliva I'm not
loosey-goosey on stage it out of it
comes off or whatever I just know that
when my boys are nice and loose it's a
better you know I do that with shirts oh
yes for years I everyone I always wear
the bowling everyone's like Barney
where's bowling shirts all the time what
do you need I go no because they're the
only shirts to make my gut not look Tony
Soprano shirts like I wear them forever
and toy lost enough weight where I
couldn't and then like once this winter
I'm like I got to go back to the Tony
Soprano shirts
I I stopped wearing shirts all together
on stage yes I bet worn a shirt on stage
in two years I literally haven't want to
show because I because that same thing
yeah I look and I know this doesn't make
any sense to anyone else but I look fat
in a shirt yeah like I look fat and
shirt no drugs without a shirt I don't
actually don't even look that fat like
right it sounds really crazy but like
when a dress shirt gets tight around the
belly and you move and you can see it
not move with the body and not hang I
look fat and and I was getting self
conscious of it i was talking my young
starters it was at the time in
occupational therapy she was I mean it's
rearing its head again but she is as she
develops her [ __ ] kid's brain is just
[ __ ] wired very [ __ ] different like
wired like a like like Tony Soprano's
like just a interesting like almost
deviant almost like [ __ ] bizarre like
it really ignorance what is occupational
therapy to go down and if you don't want
no no I've always talked about this no
but I mean I and that's what I mean if
everyone's heard of oh no no no I don't
talk about this much oh but like I don't
mind talking about it uh it is um
they're dicks you ever problems with
kids were like they put on their like
their socks felt weird did you ever know
anyone like that their socks or what
like you'd put on socks then you put on
shoes on the socks and this the socks
felt weird in the shoe because the seam
on the toe or like or like oh yeah well
people who would unlike don't like tabs
on the bed okay back of the shirts or
more like there's a something on their
in their pants and their pants feel
weird okay basically tactile she's got
tactile issues which I have meaning like
I can only wear certain types of things
that I feel comfortable in like isn't
that everybody though I know it borders
little thing I never wear socks unless
I'm wearing boots it drives people crazy
I could never do that I could never do
that really like them because tactile II
that would make me crazy the whole
[ __ ] time okay like I don't wear
underwear because wearing pick something
under pan unlike wearing underpants
underpants would make me feel cramped
and claustrophobic like it would make me
crazy so I never wear underwear and like
there's so there's a lot of things like
I'm sure I'm miss explaining this but
that was one of the things and that was
causing uh there's you know way brains
are made sometimes are just that they
fire differently I have that brain isla
has that brain it's what they call it a
hot singlet it's like a brain that fires
interestingly sometimes it's up
sometimes it's down sometimes it loses
its [ __ ] mostly if it son dealt with as
children you end up with substance abuse
problems well hence my career but like
but like but so I don't know how we got
onto this but like I Allah has [ __ ]
tactile issues oh word the shirt thing
so so we take her to occupational
therapist as she's going through the
litany of things that were like as she's
saying it it's like a laundry list of
things that we're dealing with with Isla
I'm recognizing they're all things I've
dealt with heard my childhood and had to
just get through it and it also builds
into a anxiety attacks and panic
disorder like all these things kind of
just build into like this [ __ ]
laundry list of something that could
make someone out of their [ __ ] mind
crazier tough to deal with tough to be
around you know and so she's doing it
and I start going like as she doing it
my wife's also looking directly at me
going like this is you and I was like
this is me don't wives have a way of
looking at you at the kid like this is
all your fault yeah it's your genes and
I'm like I'm like like a Roman Empire
she's like to have a proper there's
nothing I go I go I would at the time I
was having a very hard time on stage
because I was gaining weight and I felt
like I was sweating I wasn't sweating so
I was nervous I was sweating so I was
interactive and I was excited and I
would sweat would start right am I right
here like right on my chin line and all
my armpits and then it was show up on my
back and I would it would make me think
the audience thinks I'm nervous but I'm
not nervous at all I've no nerves and I
was and like you do something we're like
you'd raise your hand and then your
shirt would stay there and that would
make me self-conscious and I said to
this lady I was like
then the ladies is very candidly so why
do you wear a shirt like when I perform
I said when I perform she knows a comic
a civil why he wear a shirt thinking um
maybe like a rock star or something and
I was like I was like I don't know why
and so I started taking my shirt off on
stage second I get almost a just ripped
my shirt off and we get such a huge
response that i was like 'oh then i put
it back on and people would boo and then
one day i was like [ __ ] i'm doing the
whole show with my shirt off ripped it
off did the whole show of my shirt off
and then and by the way five minutes in
no one notice that my shirt was off
anymore and so I was like [ __ ] it I'm
done wearing shirts on stage so I
started not wearing shirts on stage and
I haven't worn assured I'll do it
sometimes I'm doing a short set a we're
sure on stage like 15 minutes I think I
remember following you it's SF punchline
and you had your shirt off yeah I'd like
two years ago and the crowd made me take
my shirt off and it was much worse I
like it was like and everything it was
ok set but I'm like yeah like yeah when
I good you know don't like what happened
it was like yeah I don't know they may
burn had his shirt off in any took my
shirt off I you know it wasn't that that
is my my I just talked you know how your
life you just remember now I remember I
remember that exactly was a Sunday night
like two years ago it's it's it's and
then you start like like there's certain
things i used to like wearing boots on
stage then like Rogan said something to
me he was like this isn't what he said
but this is what I heard like what if
you have to get away like that sounded
so odd like not that I don't mean that
can't be what he said but he's like I
was always wear sneakers on stage what
if you have to get away or I don't we
were all [ __ ] up who knows what he
said but that's what I heard like what
if you have to get away no nose like
nano or wear boots I need sneakers and I
started thinking like I'd be on stage
and I noticed my boots win that must
track him I was like [ __ ] I need to get
away really I so now I were sneakers on
stage I tried to be as comfortable as I
possibly can on stage without lowering
the decorum of the room I would wear for
my set like like if it's like a friday
night I'll always wear you know like
Club always were or like with bill or
Lisa what everyone always wear like
black pants nice shirt in my most calm
fortable black shoes yeah and like
everything everything after that is
lower and low or just shy of nursing
shoes yeah well I I have a pair of
really comfortable dress shoes that you
don't you know that you don't have to
tie to just step into yeah so then these
are like my nice 10 issues i wear for
every other set that isn't it basically
like if i'm getting paid which is mostly
time if I'm just trying out stuff I
don't really care what it looks like but
if I'm getting paid I try to up the ante
oh and I got and other than that I want
to be as comfortable as possible with
without looking terrible this you know
you mean like the best conversation I've
ever had on my podcast okay because and
this is something I hope every comic is
listening to right now what you wear on
stage is something some guys pay no mind
to like and then some guys like myself
I've been obsessive about it I've been
obsessive about what I wear on stage
because when I first started I didn't
give a [ __ ] I really didn't give a [ __ ]
and then someone said something to me
and it got my head I used to wear
flip-flops on stage and for the first
[ __ ] at ten no not 10 not ten for the
first probably two years of doing
stand-up I did I wore flip flops on
stage every time and and I wore the same
flip-flops que no flip-flops from west
from Key West they're up there were my
most comfortable flip-flops I wore them
every single day I wore them everywhere
I went I don't even know if I had a pair
closed toed shoes and so in New York and
so I definitely didn't have a pair of
sneakers in New York I didn't own
sneakers in New York I only know that
because I remember wanting one day going
I should get a pair of sneakers and I
was like I don't have so I don't want it
looks at to shoot out yeah your boots
you and whatever other she bloody stones
and in flip-flops yeah he knows yeah and
they were mine and I felt like those
define me and then one day I go to host
at the at the Hollywood improv I move
out to LA I get I had to by the way I
had a [ __ ] TV show I wore flip flops
every day on the TV show every [ __ ]
day and so I go to do i go to host of
The Improv and Freeman's standing at
like I don't know what I don't
I mean you remember the old improv looks
like but like the eye I'm trying to
judge it now but like where the DJ booth
was there used to be like a little place
where comics would be around yeah bud
was on the step down right by the door
and I walked up and I was on the step up
and he just put some monocle and he goes
mr. crusher you know we have a closed
toed shoe policy on this club I mean I'm
assuming you're gonna be changing shoes
before you show and I was like yes sir
and I ran out to my car and I had my
blood stones in my car and I put them on
and I have never worn flip flops sense
and that because that one moment and I
went and then and and then one time I
wanted to wear my flip-flops and
someone's like no man you the boot guy
and I went off [ __ ] and then I got all
in my head I look at Louie and like what
he wears on his specials and I wonder
and here's a question I'll put out do
you do you do you dress the same every
time you go on stage including a special
or would you go trying stuff out outfit
working with biller Lisa outfit special
outfit I I would lean that way so I lean
that way like something like free for a
lot of time when Lisa had always were a
sport coat that's because she was in a
more dressed up phase i kinda if it's
New Years Eve like when Bill dressed up
then I get dressed up but I never out
dressed that the the headliner of a
theater so do you like this oh so like
say you're doing New Year's Eve bills
wearing a suit I wear suit but I wear my
sorta suit I don't wear a tie and I
always wear black jeans but you can't
tell it's black jeans open if it's New
Years Eve will be the red shirt red
handkerchief a black coat I always I
almost always wear black when i'm on a
real set i always wear black pants and I
always have black in like there might be
some red up here or some blue or some
white Tony super but it's always mostly
black and that's what Molly you know you
know Molly yeah she didn't I mean we've
been we were best friends forever still
were like brother sister she didn't see
me in in blue jeans until I moved to LA
she's I've never seen you in the parable
ood really yeah
what now I can I tell you sure I feel
like like I'm doing a special uh I think
in january or december january maybe
even februari if at the rate this
[ __ ] bookings going but like I'm
doing a show time or a special I
shouldn't tell you for who but maybe I
should who don't bleep it out yeah
whatever why do I ever they're not
listening um but uh and I was talking to
the people and I said yeah I'm
definitely doing it shirtless like I'm i
can even done stand-up why would I put
on a suit I have a warning suit I don't
want to stand up in suits I haven't worn
a collared shirt on stage now that I
mean interrupt but what why did what
tonight show Jimmy Fallon would they let
you be topless or I wouldn't tell them
and you take your shirt off first of all
they'll never booked me to do stand-up
but like okay why I mean no I mean I
just say that because I oh my they
booked me to do stand-up but then I'd go
in tell one story and then I'm sure
after they heard the story they'd be
like that's a much better panel story
okay cuz like that's what happened with
Letterman is like I was booked to do the
show and everyone assumed it would be
stand up and then when they looked at my
material they were like this is he's
doing panel oh yeah just tell a story of
Dave and then he can interact it's
better it's better than just doing like
me going monologuing a story about
[ __ ] fighting a bear you know scuba
diving right so um but if I did stand-up
on Fallon if they really want you to do
six seven six minutes tell this story
I'd walk right out it I wouldn't tell
them I just take my shirt off I'd taking
me a handheld mic I don't want to be
miked I'd walk out I take my shirt off
and I start stand up that way and I
cancel it or not but I'm doing it my way
I might appoint my career where I'm so
and I had this in a dream last night
I've been dreamt to this I'm so tired of
the way I [ __ ] up when I was younger
by trying to conform to what i thought
was successful that now i don't give a
[ __ ] like it was it was the biggest
misstep in my career was and I was by
the way I was fairly successful like I
was on TV shows and I was booking stuff
but what was the stuff the times I
succeeded I was I was like [ __ ] it I'm
doing it my way I'm tired of it but
book I remember like getting brought
calling the producers at doing a read
this back whenever e1 read for like 20
sitcoms a season and I did it the way I
thought they'd look for the character to
do they wanted the character I could
read it and they're like so I did it
like okay like high energy and there
were and they're like this is great
bring him to producers actually yeah
bring it was the first time I ever went
this is a little anyway so I go to
producers and then I come in and I do it
that way and they're like that's amazing
and then they're like we want you to do
a woman we're gonna bring in Tallinn
oily an improv and I was like okay and
then the improv I couldn't keep up the
character cuz I was like I don't know I
don't know and I was like what the [ __ ]
am i doing do I want to be that guy do I
want to be Kramer for the rest of my
[ __ ] life right and uh so now I'm
like if I was gonna do found I just
ripped my shirt off I wouldn't I would
never tell them ok ok I just want you
know that's what you know wanted to see
if you wanted me to panel I keep my
shirt on so I looked disgusting sitting
down definitely I keep your shirt on but
that'd be awesome to see Letterman's
face like Bert its but I think that what
I enjoyed in entertainment like there
was a vince vaughn i don't know if it's
still on there but there's a vince
vaughn clip a long time ago of him
telling a story to david letterman this
like very beginning of his career I like
98 and it is so [ __ ] good and it's
clear that Vince Vaughn has respect for
Letterman but he doesn't give a [ __ ]
right and I and I remember watching that
going that's what that's what a star is
when they not give a [ __ ] yeah and they
really don't give a [ __ ] when you see
someone giving a [ __ ] it's just so sad
yeah it's it's not and it's not what
makes us entertaining you know yeah I
guess I mean you know I don't find very
many people entertaining really who do
you like who do you like watching doing
stand-up BRR Jim Jefferies yeah I wish I
saw more you remember we're talking at
The Comedy Store you're like I never
play around here that's all right that's
why I came down about my wife we came to
see you yeah like we never get to see
Bert Kreischer you know I feel like
uh-uh so I just the people that are out
there
um you know i love i love i love my
buddy my touring partner Paul verzi I
love he's Pulver's he's awesome um Kevin
shay oh you never know with shades it's
all the people that you don't know what
they're going to say but they're
professional enough Sam Tripoli but
they're professional enough to where
it's gonna be good or at least they've
thought about it I don't like I despise
the people that go up and think
everything that they say is funny and
they're gonna talk for four hours yeah
like I don't like that at all no like I
you know it you know I mean even like
i'ma get an eye open for Chappelle tons
of times way back free whatever pre and
you know whenever he puts it all in an
hour it's brilliant for seven hours
watching him chain smoke it's like I'd
rather watch my grandfather he's funnier
yeah chain smoking and shooting the [ __ ]
I mean I you know I like I like when
people try to put an act on and not work
out their craziness it was a it was it's
an interesting uh that's I don't like it
yes I agree it's like I find it somewhat
uh and I get maybe I don't know I can't
excite speak for Chappelle but and I
can't speak on his experiences maybe
they're all he can do is perform an
amphitheaters maybe that's the only
thing it's the only place even work out
material but like I agree with what
you're saying even though I mean I know
definitely when I saw him the other I
saw him in Seattle like last year I was
brewing with bill and were like oh we
got done we're like let's go see
Chappelle and it was him in the theater
and it was like whoa he took the four
hours the seven hours he'd do with the
punch line and put it into two yeah and
it was a different level yeah it was
amazing yeah oh I'm saying is I don't
think even people's pod cat I love Ari
Shaffir but sometimes when I see on the
thing it's three hours and 10 minutes
it's like I don't I don't want to listen
to that a [ __ ] I know I love re to
death but like when it either podcast is
he is one of the only podcast I listened
to by the way it's a great podcast you
know and I say this I'd say this to RX
on
love him yeah but it's because he's got
he's almost like socially misaligned
with the universe because he says things
to people that could be construed as
like a Barbara Walters question but he
doesn't mean it like that he means it
curiously like when listen to the one
with him and deep talk about teams
drinking yes it's [ __ ] great pocket
yeah was [ __ ] fascinating and but
already says stuff to him like no no no
you're annoying when you drink and and
and you like I would never say that to
anyone like look I mean you did a lot of
coke right like it's almost like stuff
you're like hey keep that on the DL but
that's re that's the way we robbery but
I think that's why he has a great
podcast it's what makes him great but
when you hear him monologue unless he's
talking unless he cries when you hear
him model like the fun you like you like
write that down of book work on it and
then bring it to be okay yeah but I just
mean in general just rambling about I
mean that's why I like on my couple of
podcasts we always keep them an hour
like that's it yeah I don't care who we
have we will do two parts if it's
somebody incredible like it again like I
have to break over the hour definitely
yeah under two hours over the hours good
for me yeah like I feel like it once and
I've done I've done some I've done some
long ones I did one with Doug Benson
those five hours and that was by the way
the best thing I've ever done in my life
I did one with Rogan it was five hours
on rogan podcast yeah Benson can keep
the energy up for some reason for 500
toast a note oh yeah he's another guy
that you keep it up though there's a few
guys that can't but even that okay it's
a podcast you can like okay I'm in the
car listen to why I get tele accident
I'll be done for an hour than in the
plane maybe I'm like I'm stage though
that's oh yeah but that's just keeping
people hostage here's the deal a
stand-up comic a stand-up comedy show
should be 50 minutes wow I think if
you're gonna do not a whole show I
wouldn't have a career thing because the
people didn't bring me with them I met
like when I'm on stage speaking I should
speak for 50 minutes that's it I think
that's not you perceive it I think like
I always feel like when people say God
yeah you gotta do 45 but do as much as
you want i can count on one hand how
many times I've gone over an hour cuz I
just don't have that much to say
count I couldn't count on all the hands
in this room and at my daughter's school
how many [ __ ] times I ran over an
hour like I've gone I've gone my my
disease is if i if i get if i don't get
off at the top of the at the hour then
it's definitely an hour 15 it'll
definitely be an hour 15 you always have
to hit the out you always have to hit
the the 15 or half or it'll be it'll be
an hour 25 it'll be an hour 30 like I've
gotten off stage I was like that wasn't
bad and and you see the whole wait staff
sitting by the bar and they're like
really cuz we would like to go home and
and by the way I'm and I say this in
there's not one wait staff in the
country that doesn't like me however
when I go [ __ ] long they all [ __ ]
hate me well here's a here's something I
always notice about least about me that
my best shows or when a waitress is
crying like when the crowd is that crazy
or angry or drunk yeah that's that's by
crowd if you get back how was a show and
the managers like shaking his head
because to wages are crying and there's
a cops are outside like then I that's
what I'm selling CDs like that's my best
crowd there's a you know the energy then
is like people always like you know I
don't like you know be usually like the
early shows are might or use the worst
for me cuz those are like the people a
day to the people don't want to hear
what I have to sit or that you know what
I mean those are the through I can't
believe you said like people looking at
me like but delayed show it's like those
are my those people that were can't get
there by eight yeah I I feel like I feel
like when I first started I wanted are
the late shows were the ones that I like
the best yeah now I feel like I the late
shows for me our absolute chaos might
have so many true fans though y know I
have a lot of but I have a lot of fans
who love [ __ ] drinking right and so
those late shows they start drinking at
eight yeah totally tailgating your show
and yeah and then all of a sudden like
like I'm not even joking like ambulances
are coming dudes are seizing up like I
the guy sees up at a table I think I
fall face forward onto the table split
his head open like it is that is the
[ __ ] you're like the stones do the
trouble happens
is it is hey I'm pretty cool though acme
i [ __ ] is again you have fans that
great i like it you don't like it
because it's fun but then now i look at
the early shows it's like a fun place
like and my early shows pretty much are
like a sober spot where i do like where
I'm working and I'm really having fun
but I'm having funks I'm doing stand-up
my late shows sometimes have turned into
these [ __ ] like these like I'm a
rodeo clown yeah that's what's so great
about working with bill is even you play
these theaters we're having a minute
even I don't anything drinking past the
like the gate you know yeah and they're
so into stand-up that they're listening
to everything you're saying and you're
thinking man oh these jokes are great
then you go try to play him in the beer
hall and they're just like people look
at you like they're not on that
wavelength of genealogy whatever they're
not trying to think and being the joke
they're worried about like I know we
ordered for margaritas not to I should
join it I used to tour with jay mohr for
a long time yeah and he always had sold
out shows I mean it sold out two on
thursday two on friday three on Saturday
two on Sunday sold out [ __ ] like ona
comedy fans like and you just say
anything and we just murder and then and
I remember thinking I remember thinking
the time like I am the greatest comic
lie I am top five top five guys under 30
that's me right now like no questions
asked and then I started headlining the
same like the same jokes that were
destroying we're now crickets and I was
like and I and I had to do ours and I
was like [ __ ] but you learn like
part of that is it's this weird getting
confident on stage and then when you go
out as a headliner like turning that
corner of going ok now I got to figure
out how to make [ __ ] strangers laughs
right making strangers laugh is the
hardest [ __ ] thing a lot in the world
well yeah you know I mom imagine I'm
actually coming I know I almost
different I mamas in a different way
because I think I've made strangers
laughs forever until maybe two or three
years until working with like bill
well we'll know in the sense like right
before I left the Bay Area I was
starting to get fans oh yeah like fans
yeah fans of me and then you move to LA
and they only bill and like you know
whatever and Sarah slim and draw
everybody else is like who gives a [ __ ]
all right but so but now when I go
around and so but now between my puck
off and a few other things and people
knowing me from bill shows I kind of
have more fans around the country so now
I feel like people are coming to see me
and it's easier but I think the whole
rest of the time I've only been making
strangers laugh yet no I you know
anything like yeah you know what I agree
with what you're saying I was not that
guy okay I was I was I was making
exchange life in New York for a short
period of time unless I think I started
touring with uh Jay maybe I was like
four years n through four years and
three years and four years in and I
remember at one point being in a room as
me Rob Cantrell Barry cats and Rob
Cantrell was like how long's burp and
doing it and I remember Barry single
Bert's an anomaly he found his voice
very quickly and I was like four years
and he was like what and I was like
heaven only doing it for years I started
when I was 26 and I was 30 at the time
that that conversation happened and I
was and I was like I thought I was on
fire and then and then you don't know
you get to headlining get that I mean
one of the things i miss really is like
not and not miss I mean I don't say I'm
like longing for this or pining for this
moment but being unknown going into like
the Dayton funny bone and doing an hour
of [ __ ] really great I've never heard
of you material and they're like and
people are lined up to be like that was
your great we saw its [ __ ] good
tribal to smoke monger who came in last
week and he's been our favorite but
you're our favorite name I missed those
days a little bit you know what I mean
yeah now I know I mean I'm I'm lay still
in the AL you are you're great it's some
way still in that phase but I know what
you mean though I totally know what you
mean just having people come up and go
that was great we know who you were you
know it I'll tell you that and that's
kind of like the difference between
working with Lisa and working with Bill
kids would wait okay do that for me what
is the difference between working with
Lisa and work with Bill like
working with lisa is and for those you
not listening Lisa lampanelli's
Lampanelli uh queen of mean I can't
imagine anyone would think it's another
lease I there's not in comedy not
anything lease is almost like Prince
right bartek you're acting crazy [ __ ] uh
with Lisa they they might not know now
that I've been with her seven eight
years almost you know the day almost the
best is when they come up cuz I'm
nervous hey you're always playing I'm
doing a half hour I think I'm always
playing the greatest hits yes that's all
you buying it always kills I want to
keep that job that's the best thing yeah
I can't get a real job like as good as
that oh yeah yeah yeah so um I'm always
playing hits but you know after only a
few years and I'm I got five minutes to
myself and so it and then you keep
adding new stuff more comfortable but
what people come up and go we love the
new stuff then you're like oh right
because the whole time I'm like these
people bend it like Chicago five times
like yeah with her anyway the difference
really is is that with the Queen people
don't know who you are and for the first
time at least but they assume you're
well it this way first of all playing
any theater with anybody I the people
who you are it must be tough going out
there it's not tough people pay
seventy-five bucks to go see a comedy
show if you have an act and you're funny
you're where the wood you're no it's all
over the walls you're gonna you're gonna
kill ya or you're gonna do well yeah so
that's it's not like it's not no it's
awesome most awesome thing in the world
it's like it's like it's like batting
cages yeah yeah it's yet for like
they're not gonna get beam and if you do
your dad's gonna go complain and they'll
give me money back yeah so so that's so
that's it's all gravy it's all awesome
but with the Queen it's like they think
they don't dig they don't think that
they think your faith they think you're
famous because you're with the Queen cuz
the Queen transcends comedy like there's
people that wouldn't know would know
bill burr Dave Attell or Bert Kreischer
if they if they can hit by the car but
they know the Queen yeah so they they
they just think you're liking some
sitcom
I never saw before like like so you know
so you're just even being in front of
her it puts you to a level of like you
know her how if you know where you must
be successful yeah and you're maybe
fighters is growling this guy oh my god
what show are you i don't know like you
signing autographs is like oh my god
you're amazing you know where with bills
their more their comedy people it so
you're more like in the envelope of like
these are the comedies highest fans per
se yeah like they know good stuff so you
want to give them a great show and then
would they respect the great show and
they're like you're a great comic or
what I'm not trying to no no no I got
you know got it I got it you ready for
this analogy yes okay tell me if this is
a cure okay I working with lisa is like
she's like Starbucks everyone's familiar
and if your CD is showing at the front
of starbucks you got to be good like if
your CDs at the counter of starbucks you
got to be [ __ ] good right working
with bill is like an artisan coffee shop
where you go in and and if your cds in
there you're like listen this is [ __ ]
this is hip this is this is gonna be hot
I'm gonna this isn't gonna be my best
this is gonna be my favorite CD because
they they go in for that I don't know
why I'm using CDs an example i should
say flavors of coffee but like but like
bills like an artisan coffee shop that's
big but it's not like it's not like
across the country in every market Lisa
I think that's even better like bills is
in all of the places you like bills
would be in you know whatever all the
hip towns we're lost in yeah oh like
yeah we drive to austin to get bills get
to get bills coffee you can't get bills
coffee in Corpus Christi yeah kinda let
that kind of thing and and and leaves
coffee is definitely in Corpus yeah
Lisa's coffee sold in Walmart's lease is
it big I I want it but I'm not trying to
nag you any any kids are they're both
yeah i mean the bad i've always wanted
to us I always wanted to pay this
compliment to Lisa Lampanelli but I've
never gotten to meet her officially is
this is a very very long time ago um we
it's been something I'm
ways and by the way it's so lost now
because it's not it's like it would have
been a great compliment like eight years
ago when she didn't know how big she was
about to become or maybe 10 years ago
when she wasn't when she was just
selling out clubs right I was doing a
show called hurt Burt on FX and I had to
be a male stripper for a day and so I
went and I was a male stripper at a
girls club and then they said all right
time to turn it around now you're gonna
be a male stripper at a gay club you
need to win the strip contest at a gay
club so we're in Vegas we went to an all
male gay club and I went up and had to
compete against about again against the
buses shows the person who won I mean
this is my mind you I'm a comic i go in
i do my striptease it's okay I no one
really cheers for me some guys pity
throw money at me the person who won was
dressed as leap Lisa Lampanelli and they
played her comedy album and he
lip-synched her comedy album and I
thought that is [ __ ] the high my god
again I saw the Queen that i'll let you
doing no no no you tell her I'll never
speak to her like like the the I was
sitting in the back and I'm a comic
comic at the time I've been doing it for
one long enough where I'm headlining
right and I'm in the back and I here
ladies and gentlemen put your hands
together for Lisa Lampanelli and she cut
and this woman comes out dressed as Lisa
Lampanelli or a man a man comes out
dressed Lisa Lampanelli and they are all
the gay guys it's the routine that she
has about gays they're [ __ ] howling
laughing and he's just lip synching it
hey uh and i went i sat in the back and
I went what and I'm by the way I knew
Lisa when we were in New York cuz I
worked the door the Boston comedy club
this before she was who she was she used
to wear like a gold Mercedes emblem and
gold rings and like she dressed up like
she was Flavor Flav right and so I would
sit I knew her I knew her enough that
she wasn't headlining and i would say hi
to where she would be nice and we'd talk
yeah but i sat in the back having known
this person in New York and I went oh my
god and I thought this woman I didn't
know how big she was at the time right
is about to be coming [ __ ] huge if
had a gay club the person who won
the striptease contest didn't take off
any other clothes and just lip-synched
her [ __ ] comedy album I was really
that I met that's stuck in my class
that's a great story its of no I mean
that's really that's insane dude it's
really insane it's fun when you it's fun
when you as a comic you're in the know
and you see other people get excited for
someone you know very well and yeah and
like like I liked I really enjoy it with
bill because I think we've all known
that bill has been succeeding very well
for the past probably like six years
like been just moving up what would you
say like 55 years I think he's been
doing theaters right um i would i would
think so yeah i'm yeah i remember
running into him one time you've been
definitely like selling out clubs for
probably eight or nine tell ya but like
like recently just like tour boss big
like yeah [ __ ] let him in verse ii
are doing the garden in november not the
hey we're doing the via the garden like
the Knicks yeah and but it's fun to
watch people arrive on how hey like you
go on facebook and one of your friends
is like dude have you heard this bill
burr guy and I was like have I heard of
bill burr like [ __ ] yeah 16 years ago
when all he was is red like like inside
like like inside like like inside like
like inside like like inside like like
inside like like inside like like inside
like like inside like like inside like
like inside like like inside like like
inside like